that's cool
so thanks for having me here I'm very
happy to be able to talk about the
liberal UFT protocol which is the
protocol that we have developed for the
Libre blockchain this is a joint work
with many people obviously some of them
from the research group are in this room
that yeah Mikey draw that is Alberto
Santino and before I start I would say I
can make your tests maybe if you were to
choose a BF te consensus protocol for a
major block chain and let's say you're a
CTO with with the background in in
science but not another specialist what
is the one one thing you will ask about
this protocol
how much you gonna pay the person that
oh that's interesting issue that should
remember that all right okay so so I
think maybe one thing you can ask is
like you'd like to have a proof of
safety and the protocol that you
actually understand or you think you
understand okay so and so we were lucky
to to meet the authors of the of the
hostile protocol early on in our project
and I think it's purchased it as the one
thing that we really like about this
protocol that we we had the sense that
we kind of understand the proper safety
he was it was kind of concise on top of
being using like a very very strong body
eventually synchronous and and then we
also felt like okay the protocol looks
like really efficient we got this nice
linearity response nephew
responsibilities which I will talk about
later and pipelining and so we're okay
well this is it
we just need to implement it in theory
everything is done but maybe the Prime
Minister you know there's always a a bit
of difference between theory and
practice although in theory it is known
so and so I did I should down everything
alright
so and so we started working and and so
here the the catch is that the pacemaker
I mean that the nice thing about how
stuff is you you can really prove safety
and and and and to some extent proving
liveness well abstracting away a big
chunk of the redirection and so that's
the part that was missing and so this is
the reason why we I'm here today is
because in libera BFG we made precise
what we need to achieve lightness and we
in fact we want it to be really built in
the protocol because I mean like if you
go to an engineering team you say a
thanks for building the protocol now you
need to build another protocol for
direction they tend to not like it so
much they think like when they combine
everything is gonna be hard to debug
everything so so we really want to
combine everything which is also kind of
kind of standard for for many blockchain
protocols and so it's talk so I will
stop by I mean I'm sure many of you know
they're also protocol but I'm going to
revisit nonetheless using librar DFT or
annotations and so you might not is some
but some difference in there here and
there and then I'm going to go into the
main topic of the of the talk which is
the run synchronization that we
developed for Libre BFG and in fact I'm
going to present the version 1 and
version 2 and version 2 being the most
interesting I think and if I have time
at the end I will try to conclude with a
number of general comments on the on the
madera we're using 4 or everybody in
Ukraine actually is using for a state
machine replication ok so I'm gonna
start with the core hot stuff protocol
within the bar BFT so how does it work
so as you know there's our leader based
protocol so let's cool so let's say we
we have a round number and the leader is
deduced from the round number ok what we
expect from a leader is to and I'm going
to actually use the noise
the diagrams to what you expect from a
leader is to together watch whatever
user transactions you you want to
execute in the blockchain put that into
something we call the command to do
comment into a block sign it broadcast
the block and to everybody ready to set
and what you hope is that everybody's
gonna reply they're going to carry on a
number of verifications and and if they
like your block they're gonna reply with
the with the vote and once you have a
crumb of votes you can aggregate them
and create what we call a quorum
certificate and then any bra vft you
would the leader with the would simply
rebroadcast the chrome certificate and
that concludes the round of this leader
so what's interesting with hot stuff
it's also there's an extra data
structure in particular so we expect his
vote to contain the hash of a block we
expect a quorum certificates to contain
to be linked to the block that is
actually certified but in the bribe BFT
we also expect the blocks to contain a
hash with the previous the corn
certificate of a previous block so this
gives the structure of chain that is
interesting and you can see that for
instance if we agree on the Block B -
well we have to agree on everything that
is before so and this was well explained
in the presentation so earlier there's
the idea of pipelining that this
certification here satisfies not only B
- but the satisfaction of b1 so you you
see where I'm going here we and
obviously we want around to be
increasing along the changes part of the
condition for for validity that is
checked when you're about to vote for a
four block so it's here I'm going here
we now we can in fact very easily state
commit rule which is the following if I
know a chain that has that ends with
three QCs and the round numbers happens
to be contiguous so let's say one two
three in this example then I can look at
the first block of my coming true and
say okay well this thing is committed
but as I mentioned before what's nice
since we are training everything not
only I come in this book but I commit
everything any any other block
previously not not committed that would
appear earlier in the chain and in the
right order as you imagine okay so okay
so now why do we care about continuous
rounds so this is going to appear in the
proof of safety but I guess the another
question is like why is it the case that
sometimes you'd have non continuous
rounds and this in fact this is really
cheap this is this happens when the
leader doesn't do its job and that's
kind of the only thing we we need to
know about view changes you know
there's no view change right this is
just a gap in a round number
so I just explained the committe rule
now we'd like to know whether this
actually works whether that's this
enforces safety in terms of the absence
of pork in the protocol and so so safety
comes at a price the nodes have to in
addition to the well for most of the one
firmness of the blocks the the nodes
have to do a few verifications that are
called safety rules so and that involves
tracking two integers to run numbers so
nodes must remember for any block the
bullet for they must remember the round
and they must remember the round of the
grandparent of that block okay and and
you'd so you need to remember the
maximum number for for those two values
and every time you're going to vote for
a blog you check that the run of the
block is greater so that the round of
any previously bodybugg and you need to
verify the round of the parent of the
block is greater or equal than the run
of any grandparent of what it block in
the past and that's not a typo this is
really parent and one parent here
although it makes semesters and so the
nice thing with those two rules is
that's kind of all you need to know to
prove the safety of hot stuff so I
actually made the exercise to gather
everything you need in one slide
probably I don't have time to go over
the proof this is the main lemma that
says if I have a block with the QC at a
higher or equal round then the block
address committed then I know there is a
path there's a chain that goes from the
to commit to my block okay and so why
does it prove safety well this thing so
first this diagram lives in the union of
everything the nodes know okay so this
could be a committee in one node this
could be a block that is about to be
committed somewhere else and what I'm
saying is oh wait there's a chain
between this one and this one and so I
just showed that is a linear sequence
between all the commits across the
network okay so
and once again the nice thing here is
really that this slide is possible you
can have one slide for the safety proof
of of hot stuff any bra BFT okay okay
now the village just a little bit closer
i what happened what's happening in
terms of of storage and communication so
we we have those chains of blocks and it
might seem like oh we find ourself
having to synchronize a tree of blocks
and QCs over the network but actually in
practice you can show you need only to
remember the highest commit rule you
ever saw and the chain that precedes the
highest qcu ever so so that's only two
chain and they are mostly equal also
when everything is good then you have in
fact only one chain and and you can show
that the the communication at least the
number of messages is linear in the
happy case and if you're using fresh
signature that's strictly in error in
terms of network complexity okay alright
so that's for for the safety core of hot
stuff
are there any and questions so far
everything is
maybe okay how about lightness so or QC
so we want to create a comment right so
for QC to be created so all the honest
notes needs to be to agree on the round
number otherwise they will be surprised
to see this block being created by
somebody they don't expect the leader
will be honest to propose and all the
known must vote for the proposed block
right so that's this stage we're talking
about the voting so why is it to concern
that all the nodes need to vote while we
as I just explained for safety we just
added the students we just added these
two constraints okay so the question is
like as a leader how do I propose my
block to make sure that people can
actually vote for it meaning that these
two constraints are going to pass for
every valid other every other validator
and I think it's fair to say that one of
the main contribution of hot stuff and
this sticking point is that to propose a
block you don't need to wait a fixed
Delaine you just need to count a number
of samples n minus f rounds of QC given
to you by people that just entered you
around okay so once again you and let's
say in tandem in for instance you have
you would only wait for a fixed delay
and then you propose okay so in the in
ha staff you you wait for n minus F news
to join you around and tell you what is
their highest QC round okay
when that happens you take the highest
number and that's where you need to
extend the chain and if you do that you
are granted that people are going to be
able to vote for for your proposal which
means that that's what the the prime we
had for for the rightness so what's left
here is the two other points the honest
node needs to agree on the round number
and the leader must be honest the second
point means in particular if the leader
is dishonest we need to be able to skip
that round in a timely manner
hopefully this whole program is called
round synchronization or so leader
election
okay so it's very simplified way so we'd
like to know what happens between the
the red dotted line that is actually
making notes switch to the next round
okay so once again if we take the point
of view of like very practitioner so we
starting from a network that is very
nice you know you have really seems like
you I really have the minimal amount of
messages in there that is able to grant
in safety and now we're going to add
stuff to it so we would like to add the
minimum amount of overhead okay
also if we add something we'd like to
know that actually it's efficient so
we'd like to know that even if you have
Byzantine nodes in the system and the
network is scheduling your messages in
the wrong order subject to the Delta
delay after just you would like to know
that still the commit latency is fine
so like I said in hot stuff ran
synchronization is the delegated to an
external protocol actually we recently
we were studying what this external
protocol could look like in a separate
line of work in tournament the the
protocol includes round synchronization
and he is using timeouts and progress to
gossip so the natural thing to do that
we did in libera btv one was to try to
make something similar work okay and in
the Barbie 52 we thought okay it works
but we don't really like probabilistic
gossip because it's a nonlinear amount
of messages including in the best cases
also you know like introduced probably
probably a probabilistic behavior in a
system so it's a little more difficult
to debug what's going on when you look
at the at the exchanges between the
nodes so and this is the result of Saleh
Bob if T is the result of this attempts
so
now I'm going to introduce okay how the
run synchronization works in Libra B of
T so the first idea and it's still
pretty pretty reasonable I would say
we're gonna add the maximum duration to
every run number after the maximal
duration is rich every node creates a
timeout object and broadcast it okay now
when do you move to the next round you
move to the next round when you I've
seen a quorum of votes or QC as before
or when you have seen a crumb of
timeouts which we call a timeout
certificate okay so so here we see that
like leader the the last node was
supposed to be the leader the leader
doesn't do anything everybody starting
starting broadcasting timeouts and after
and so after receiving their I mean
their own timeout plus two more they
switch to the next round
and this node apparently was the leader
and ideally would like this node to
immediately broadcast a new proposal
okay
so that would be a solution with almost
no overhead a second ID while we at it
since we we are already communicate
change we're gonna when we do that and
as that's also related to the notion of
chain since we are about we we want to
communicate entire change with people
every time there's an arrow in this
diagram what it means is I'm telling you
a summary of everything I have and then
you ask me what you're missing okay so
that's the second idea that could help
for liveness okay and it's still pretty
natural and so the the question now is
alright are we good to go
is this protocol BFG life right and so
the answer is no not quite
first there is something I told you that
I haven't really implemented yet I told
you a it's awesome we are optimally we
are responsive because we can propose
after receiving n minus F message from
the people that just joined around okay
but I haven't implemented that so in
fact what could happen is that everybody
that joins my round if I'm leader number
3 everybody needs to talk to me to say
hey I just turned around and this is my
highest QC by the way but then we see
that we introduce some latency here
because now as the leader of round 3 not
only so I after I joined my round I I
need to count the number of red arrows
coming in and and so that means use a
little bit of delay so question would be
okay can we avoid that and then a second
problem is the what if leader is
dishonest
it doesn't really broadcast bqc
correctly so what could happen is that
you have a leader that only broadcast
the QC to a subset of F plus 1 nodes
gather at +1 votes then use F malicious
keys to create a QC and then you Ted
take this QC and you show it only to the
people you were talking to in first
place which means you have F note
that haven't heard about your your new
QC so they stick their stuck at the
previous round and then if the next
leader is dishonest you can repeat so
that's not necessary or prime because of
course eventually you're gonna have a
Honus leader but it's not bad for if you
are really into analyzing the latency of
the system very precisely and also a
good question to ask why
so anybody FTP won by the way this is a
solve entirely by using proper EC gossip
so there's no way for somebody to censor
I mean to selectively disclose the QC
because everybody is reassuring
everything so anybody if tv2 would like
to remove the gossip okay so we're gonna
we are going to have some kind of
problem like this for some time
so the question we can ask ourselves is
okay as long as you have these earnest
leaders they can forget to put a part of
the of the network but the next leader
that is honest can this letter do a good
job nonetheless
okay that's if you are really into
having a system that goes back very
quickly and tracked after a problem
that's the nice property to have so the
solution that we developed that I call
fast proposal is a tweak a very simple
trick on the definition of the of the
protocol of the libra of the digestion
one protocol and so I'll tell you what
we obtained before telling you what is
the modification what we obtained is
that I can propose a block as soon as I
receive one of those green arrows so if
anybody in the system joins my round
they are going to send me a notification
first they are going to convince me to
join this round if I haven't already and
second they are going to convince me to
give me enough material so that I can
propose a block right away what is
interesting with this as a byproduct is
like when I propose a block
I'm also synchronizing the entire chain
that is before that block which means
that I'm also completing the broadcast
if needed and bringing everybody to my
round so the property is that if
somebody joins around and after after
GST if somebody joins the road at time T
t plus 2 Delta everybody else is that
easy that round he's at this round okay
okay and the way you achieve that very
quickly is a you inject the highest QC
round inside the timeout object and you
change the safety rule to prevent
somebody from voting if they ever
created a timeout for this round okay so
when you when you do that you can show
that in fact the time the TC thing
counts as an - an F samples of highest
QC so that's exactly what you need to
propose and that was also already the
case for for QC alright okay are we done
yet
well not quite which is the same problem
with incomplete broadcast that we just
discuss with the QC s we can have it
with TCS so what could happen is that
you you have a leader at 1k let's say
it's slow and the next one doesn't want
to help
so the attacker waits for half plus 1 on
its node to timeout at the round K okay
and then things they have +1 and
completes that into a quorum again and
that gives the attacker a TC and they
can do whatever they want with the TC
and so what they're going to do is to
give it to people who haven't timed out
yet at this ROM and since that's going
this is going to bring in this case than
on node number 2 to the round to the
next round and so it means that in the
system except for the TC that the
attacker just created there is not
enough time outs - for the honnest notes
to move to the next round yet ok so at
this point you have one node that is at
1 at around 3 everybody else this node
was was my chest it states that it's not
responding so everybody is going to wait
at round two they have already timed out
so for them from their point of view
their job is done they are waiting for a
TC to happen and the TC is not happening
because this node is already at the next
round
ok so what is going to happen is
eventually this node is
to timeout as aslant at the next round
and then it's going to propagate the
Bison time to see but the whole thing to
took intuitively twice as much time as
before when we were using gossiping the
whole thing was was taking only duration
k now it takes duration k plus duration
k plus 1 and so you see that this node
will only timeout and one at around
three after three periods of time out
and so the question neck is can we do
better we are we see that removing
gossiping is degrading in a way the the
worst case latency of our protocol can
we fix that so the solution the solution
that I that we that we developed is the
following so and we try not to ruin the
linearity of the protocol in the happy
case so what's going to happen is that a
node if after timeout nothing still
nothing happens yet it's going to stop
pulling data from everybody at a London
key interval so concretely in our case
you see that we have a node that knows
the next TC and the other nodes don't
know it after a while they have already
timed out after a while they are going
to query everybody including the node
that had the missing information which
is going to bring them to the next round
much sooner than before okay and so this
means that the next round is going to
fail also sooner than before and so we
can show that in this case to summarize
a bad leader can only cause us a delay
one plus longer duration k which is if
lambda is small it's a trade off we can
choose the lambda to be arbitrarily
small it is close enough to duration k
which was the ideal case that we had in
the case of gossiping
all right so how are we done with
liveness yet almost
so for coming to happen we need 3q C's
in the road to be created in the in the
report so we discussed the the
consequence of incomplete broadcast or
we deal with the consequence of
incomplete broadcast for for chemicals
as well that introduce one more
mechanism that is similar to the one I
just described just based on on commits
instead of rounds and that introduces
constant I the reason I'm talking about
this is because now I want just to show
you a glimpse of the final latency bound
for RIBA beef tv2 so the term that you
obtain after this
perhaps print fool painfully detail
analysis is is that you really know
under BFG assumptions after GST how much
time you need to wait for the next
commit the way you worse is you look at
the highest round between highness knows
you you find out what is the lowest n
such that 3 leaders in your a
consecutive and the timeout is large
enough and then this is the formula you
know that this is how much time you need
to wait and you are granted that commit
will happen by this time no matter what
no matter how the network is rescued
during reordering the the messages as
long as it's still synchronous Delta is
the the synchronous the bound on
okay so to conclude under liberal TV 2
so I introduced some 11's mechanisms to
that enabled us allowed us to remove
property gossip which means that we are
optimistically llanera
the linear linear network complexity in
the case of in the happy path and I
showed that the the impact on BFG
latency this the formula before it is
still limited in the report you have
more details about the the way
reconfigurations
are handled and the way we can make
linear function and the duration
function depend on the let us commit if
if you want to receive the leader
election for instance with VRS I should
mention that the whole of this there is
a reference implementation I could
minimize a minimal and France
implementation that is now available on
github this is the one I was quoted in
the report from the beginning and stay
tuned so that this is not the end of the
story there will be future versions of
the protocol and I have maybe one more a
couple of more minutes so just a few
generic remarks about security so we
work in the eventual asynchronous manner
I think it's a strong by there so good
however very often in the academia the
results are only about differential
liveness and so for practice for
practical point of view it doesn't
really tell you when you are going to
commit there are a few perhaps too few
results about bounded delay and so this
is one more of them perhaps by analogy
with the concrete security reduction in
cryptography this is going to become
more more mainstream other slightly I'm
going some I kept on my controversial
statement for the end of the talk as you
can see so the the in the paper we
intentionally deviated from the usual
definition of eventual synchrony so by
allowing messages to be lost during
periods of a synchrony
which i think is more realistic because
if you don't want this you will need to
have unlimited buffer during pairs of uh
synchrony to make sure you never lose
the messages there's also the question
of whether you are malicious
Honus knows to crash and restart does do
the account as as malicious if they do
that during the period of a synchrony I
think it's fine
another interesting question that was
also discussed this week is like do we
really believe in the in this vft
assumption like one third of malicious
nodes so if if we are in a permission
model and you talk to engineers when
liveness is concerned they think that
actually one third emerges knowledge is
way too conservative so in fact that's
kind of that was one of the motivation
to aggressively optimize the network
complexity in the in the happy path for
for liberty FG if not man mashup is is
open then how do you know that f is
smaller than than one third of the nodes
it's actually kind of reckless so we try
to and this is still an open topic of
research obviously but so we try to be
future proof by already discussing some
ways to incentivize nodes in any bar b
ft and finally this is my last slide in
the BFG model we say that malicious
nodes can deviate arbitrarily from the
protocol but you know it's still at a
pretty high level of abstraction what do
we I mean if we are really serious about
it we would think that one of the nodes
are trying to to do horrible things
including on a network level for
instance they could try to inject
packets that are going to go us to make
the harness not go out of memory and
that would be a problem in practice
right
or can we can the dishonest node force I
mean along the same lines if you inject
a lot of amount of data in the network
can you in fact make the messages of the
Honus node be f as synchronously if you
do that then you have no pair of
synchrony anymore and the theorem in
fact is not going to apply anymore so
that could be a practical problem that
maybe we need more
more attention and that concludes my
talk thank you very much
[Applause]
questions before the break do you have
some ideas how you can squeeze in peace
out more performance meters because
synchronization not the cheese do do you
think you're pretty much okay so so if
you really really care about letting see
maybe you would be able you would be
okay to play la Garret n log n for
communication for the broadcast and
maybe probably still I suppose okay in
first place yeah what we would say I
mean the they are there are some anybody
is welcome to you to look at the proofs
and CEO this is no tie here but so to be
to be really if you look at you can you
can have some notion that the proofs are
tight because some factors are actually
what you need to wait what you need to
wait no matter what if you think that
the notes might be honnest so like you
need to give the notes a chance to to
perform that thing and so you need to
wait at least the amount of time out it
takes so part of that is already tight
it also Lucian
the paper we uploaded to the art yeah
right oh well so I mean there's a yes so
I took your question as the happy path
but now in the unhappy path we are still
quadratic in the number of messages
which might be unfortunate if you think
that karateka number of messages is
likely to saturate the network and bring
a synchrony to you then then you could
you could actually create like a yeah a
kind of a synchronous loop where you
timeout that breaks the network so you
timeout more and that breaks the network
and yeah and so the work with the with
Odin now that you are single man am i
any so it attempts to make the the run
synchronization strictly solely some
karate
okay so we're only - only ten minutes
[Applause]